صالح العبيدي مشاهدينا سعودي يبدع في
مهارات الحيل والخدع
على الرغم من صغر سنه شهره كبيره في الوطن
العربي بموهبته المميزه التي تعدت حدود
المملكه رئيس الاتحاد الدولي للخداع
البصري في السعوديه ومتخصص في فن الوهم
وكذلك التهكير الذهني وقراءه الافكار
العبيدي اول من قدم عرضا سحريا في مجال
الوهم بالطابع العربي في موسم الرياض
يعتبر واحد من اكثر لاعبي الخفه مشاهده في
العالم عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
بملايين المشاهدات على عدد مختلف من
التطبيقات
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الرياضه لاعب الخفه صالح
العبيدي صالح صبحك الله بالخير صباح الخير
اليوم اليوم حظناويات زين تقنيا
ههه طيب خلينا نقول بانه اليوم
راح نتحداك بانه عندنا
ربما حائط حمايه عن التهكير ما راح تهكر
اليوم لا مخ راويه ولا مخراويه ولا مخي
وبالتالي هذا الحائط اكبر من سور الصين
العظيم
الخفه لاعب خفه يعني شنو لاعب خفه شنو
تهكير
ذهني شنو تنوين
الناس اقول لك ما صدق
طيب خليني في البدايه اوضح لك او نقسمها
يلا انه مجال البصري والتنوين ومجال الوهم
مختلف تماما هي زي التخصصات عندنا يعني
مجال التهكير الذهني هو مدرسه حديثه من
التنوين المغناطيسي يعتمد على برمجه العقل
اللاواعي بكلمات معينه ونبرات صوت معينه
اما قراءه الافكار فهي تعتمد عقارات لغه
الجسد ولغه العين ونبرات الصوت فهي تدخل
في علوم السايكولوجي اما خفه اليد فهي
خداع العين بطريقه سريعه انه انا اشتغل
على جهه معينه واخليك تتشتت في جهه ثانيه
مختلفه تماما طيب كذلك عندنا فن الوهم او
الايحاء فان الوهم هو انك تتخيل حاجه تحدث
وهي غير واقعيه
طيب صالح انت تتقن كل هاي المجالات كل هاي
التخصصات يعني وين تجد نفسك اكثر وحابين
نشوف يعني هيك مثال على ما نتحدث عنه
ابهرنا اكيد اكيد طبعا كل تخصص له الطريق
الخاص فيه يعني مثال فن الوهم دائما يتخصص
في المسارح والعروض المسرحيه انك تقدم عرض
مسرحي لا يقل عن 45 دقيقه ولا يتعدى
الساعه والنصف ولكن عرض كامل يتكلم عن
الالوجين وفن قراءه الافكار وفن التنويم
المغناطيسي فهي مجالات مرتبطه ببعض كل ما
تعمقت فيها اكثر كل ما زادت عندك جوده
العرض
صالح احنا بالمنطقه عارفين هذا النوع ولا
احنا قاعدين يعني
ولا قاعد نقول لا طالع ساحر
سابقا فعلا كان الناس يعتقدون ان هذا سحر
ومخاوي اسمه يقولون ولكن الان بدو العالم
يقرون على الفن اكثر وبديت انا اطلع بعض
الاشياء البسيطه اشرحها عشان العالم
تستوعب انه هو فن مدروس ما له دخل في
السحر ولا الجن ولا
سكنهم مساكنهم
اعمل تهكير دهني
هكر له دهنيته
روح لا يا صالح
طيب طبعا اصعب شيء انك انت تتحكم بشخص او
تقرا افكار عن طريق الصوت فقط لانك تحتاج
تركيز عالي جدا
انا اسالك كم سؤال وابيك تكون صادق معاي
تمشي خطوه بخطوه معي جاهز يعطيك شفافيه
يلا قول تمام
اول سؤال حاسالك رقم جوالك السري مكون من
سته ارقام او اربع ارقام
سته ارقام جميل انا ابيك تعد من الواحد
للتسعه بصوت عالي انا بحاول اني من خلال
استماعي للعد الارقام اني اتوقع رقمك
السري تمام طيب ابيك تسمي بالله وتبدا تعد
من الواحد الان واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه
خمسه سته سبعه ثمانيه تسعه
انت تحس انه انت تنسى الارقام السريه
دائما تحط رقم واحد او رقم متسلسل او شكل
معين لان التلفون جديد حطيت اول رقم خطر
ببالي في شوي متسلسل شويه كثير
جميل لازم تشوف شاشه التليفون عشان تعرف
تعرف الرقم ولا
خلاص حافظوا في راسك
على بصمه الوجه اكثر لكن انا حافظه بس
اشوفه واكتبه
حافظه
حافظ جميل جميل جميل طيب انا الان غيرت
رقم جوالي السري والمفترض انه يكون نفس
رقم جوالك السري تمام لو في البدايه نحط
اي سته ارقام عشوائيه عندنا مستحيل يفتح
الجوال مهما كانت الارقام اي سته ارقام
عشوائيه ما حيفتح الجوال الا بسته ارقام
محدده عادل تسمح لي انك تصرح برقم جوالك
السري روح رقم رقم الحياه سعيده
طيب قول لي اول رقم كم اثنين
رقم اثنين
كمل معاي صفر اثنين كم
اثنين صفر صفر
صفر صفر
صفر واحد
واحد عادل متاكد ان هذا رقمك
اوكي
يعطيك العافيه عادل هذا باسورد جوالي
لحظه لحظه كيف خل
اني ترى حطيته لان هذا مو رقم الاساسي لكن
انا حطيتها على اساس انه هذا التلفون جديد
فبالتالي هو سهل هذا مو تطبيق اللي انت
سويته
لو كان تطبيقي عادل كان اي رقم انا حطيته
في السابق حيفتح عليه اه صح هو فعلا هو
جرب اكثر من رقم ما زبطوش طيب كيف كيف
قدرت
الامكان عادي صالح كيف قدر تعرف من رمز
الارقام
اوكي اوكي الارقام المربوطه فينا او اللي
تعني لنا شيء طريقه النطق اللي احنا
ننطقها فيها يكون فيها تركيز عالي جدا
فاحنا نلاحظ هذا الشيء سواء ارقام او
اسماء او حروف ما نطقت الصفر انا صالح
ما قلت الصفر صح دامك ما نطقت الصفر مجرد
من الواحد للتسعه يوم تتكلم يبان لي انه
في رقم او رقمين انت ما تهتم لهم فاعرف ان
الصفر شيء مهم بالنسبه لك
طب مع انه انا مثلا سمعته وهو عم بيعد من
الواحد للتسعه ما حسيت بميزه
اي واحد تحسينها بنبره صوت واحده وهنا
الصعوبه يوم يكون فقط نبره صوت يعني مثلا
لو كان قدامي البدي لانج حقه حيحكي اكثر
من صوته
لا لا انت ضيعت لازم اروح انا بغير رقم
تلفوني وكشفت تصير ثاني ان احنا نحط
التلفونات ورا طيب طالع العبيدي قواك الله
وانشاء لا اكيد مخاوي يجنن
صالح العبيدي شكرا جزيلا لك يعطيك العافيه
وشكرا للاعب الخفه صالح العبيدي من الرياض
انحضر لك ان شاء الله
العرض الجاي
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات